der müller sieben sätze sind kein
fachmann für amokläufer aber sie sind
schon fachmann für cannabis oder würde
ich jetzt mal so ich bin schon dran mit
cannabis
groß das bundesverfassungsgericht
bereits im jahre
2002 angerufen jetzt habe ich zusammen
mit fünf anderen richtern angerufen oder
liegen vorlagen die letzte die ich
geschrieben habe gegenüber 140 seiten
das ist fast eine dissertation soll ich
jetzt ausführen warum cannabis
legalisiert werden muss natürlich mache
ich das ja wir haben seit 50 jahren eine
provisions politik ist geschafft hat
hunderttausende von menschen in den
knast bringen millionen von menschen
wurden mit geldstrafen übersät einträge
in führungs zeichen jobverlust und und
und familien wurden zerstört infolge
einer angst die geschaffen wurde nämlich
dadurch dass man seit den siebziger
jahren mit der einstiegsdroge theorie ja
argumentiert das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht im jahr 1994
bereits widerlegt gleichwohl wir damit
argumentiert und raum geschmissen
weltweit vertritt dass kein
wissenschaftler und jetzt ich weiß nicht
ob ich noch zehn sekunden habe oder 20
jetzt müssen wir auf der einen seite
gucken was bringt die prohibition die
hat nichts gebracht und das ist auch
wissenschaftlicher wiesen es wird an
jeder ecke getippt in jeder haushalt im
jäger
artenreiche kiffen unternehmer kiffen ja
leer aktiven die staatsanwälte und so
weiter jetzt bringt gar nichts ich
wollte wenn sie jetzt sehen wie viele
leute tatsächlich ein schaden durch
cannabis dabei bei wie vielen und das
wird auch übertrieben bis zum
gehtnichtmehr das sind in etwa
3000 die in stationären
behandlungen sind die sind da aber trotz
der provisions politik und dann jeder
jugendliche kann an jeder ecke was
kriegen und er kriegt gestecktes zeug
und es wird teilweise um gestrecktes
zeug verkauft und daran sterben juli
weltweit ist an cannabis ist ein mensch
gestorben
das muss man sich vor augen führt jedes
jahr in deutschland 70.000 tote infolge
von alkoholismus und
verfassungsrechtlich noch ergänzend
warum richter das vorliegt ist der
allgemeinen gleichheitsgrundsatz
tangiert man darf sich totlaufen man
darf sich sogar umbringen nach der
neuesten verfassungsrechtlichen
rechtsprechung aber wenn sie vor dem
umbringen ja und das andere ist
scheitert denn als versuch ja zwei gramm
cannabis rauchen werden sie anschließend
bestraft das ist das gleiche wie anfang
der 90er jahre in londoner wurden sie
für den versuchten für den versuchten
suizid mit der todesstrafe bedroht
denn unsere die gleise ich hab ja
eigentlich gehofft dass sie das heute
auch vorsingen aber das möchte ich den
zuschauern
[Musik]
nur mal öffentlich
vor diesen dann sagen sie geben für die
entkriminalisierung alles herr müller
und wir geben jetzt mal die frage an
frau gegeben was sie davon hält so sein
wie siehst du das mit der legalisierung
sind also ehrlich gesagt relativ
leidenschaftlich es ist ja richtig also
alkohol ist sehr gefährlich und alkohol
ist erlaubt und es vermutlich
gesundheitlich tatsächlich deutlich
schädlicher als als cannabis auf einer
seite kenne ich natürlich und wir haben
gerade überleben gruppe der jungs
geredet also in diesem in diesem alter
also ende teams anfang wenn es mehr
jungs würde ich sagen als mädels die das
zeug ziemlich intensiv nutzen und wo ich
das gefühl habe das ist diese
entwicklung jetzt auch nicht so direkt
förderlich ist also die dann ebenso eine
scheiß egal mentalität entwickeln
rumhängen eben ständig alles sehr
entspannt sehen und so weiter was zu
ihren weiteren lebensweg nicht unbedingt
nützlich ist ich weiß nicht das kann ich
nicht beurteilen so zu sagen wie
gefährlich das ist ich nehme an dass
eine ganze menge eltern ganz froh sind
dass sie noch damit argumentieren können
das ist aber nicht erlaubt das ist
sozusagen eine gewisse unterstützung bei
den diskussionen darüber ist sie haben
natürlich trotzdem recht die leute
besorgen als ich trotzdem sie sie nutzen
ist trotzdem als liberaler mensch
versucht man immer die
eigenverantwortung hochzuhalten und zu
sagen muss ist ja auch dafür noch selber
also ich habe jetzt alles keine
argumente ich habe kein so richtig gutes
gefühl bei der sache weil ich
ja ja gute sache ja selber
eine frage wäre zb also wenn ich das
richtig sehe hat holland eine relativ
liberale würde ja auch in bezug auf
cannabis immer gemacht hat jetzt aber
trotzdem relativ massive probleme mit
den drogen merken aber mit anderen
drogen und also insofern dieses
nächsten
jahren werden wir das erlauben nicht
heiter sind aber nicht das aber nicht so
zu sagen dass der harte drogen markt
dadurch etwa weg käme oder oder
überflüssig sodass zumindest ist
ganz interessant
und ich glaube dass es inhaltlich falsch
ist weil das in holland darf man ganz
kleine mengen an cannabis verkaufen das
ist legal und große mengen verkauft ist
es illegal ja wenn ich jetzt ein
coffeeshop haben in amsterdam und ich
muss große mengen kaufen muss ich mich
sozusagen
mit kriminellen leuten abgeben ja also
ich bin auch total dafür dass man das
legalisiert ich finde es auch gut dass
wir jetzt einen großen
konsultationsprozess anstoßen dass man
das gesellschaftlich breit auf
nimmt er das ist nämlich dessen wichtige
themen weil wie sie frau gerschke ich
kann verstehen dass man sagt ich kenne
ich nicht und irgendwie muss es denn
sein ja aber als liberaler mensch finde
ich muss man sagen es gibt wirklich
keinen grund zwischen alkohol und kiffen
alkohol trinken und kiffen und dann muss
man sagen ja das ist das müssen wir als
freiheitliche gesellschaft außerhalb
lässt das der richtige rückkehr schloss
eine frage wenn man sagt naja alkohol am
wehr erlaubt und jetzt sollten wir das
auch tun alkohol schädlich muss man
nicht mehr sagen vielleicht sollte man
jetzt aufpassen die nächste droge zu
erlauben der wandel habe ich aber noch
hier werden sie jetzt zustimmen allein
durch die legalisierung würde der staat
jährlich 1,8 milliarden euro ein ich bin
es macht man das sind 4,5 milliarden
einsparungen der justiz durch steuern
und habe daher einen 1,8 das sind reine
steuer aber sie haben auf der anderen
seite haben sie ja die möglichkeit ja
bei der polizei einzusparen wir haben
die möglichkeit die leute in den knästen
besser zu behandeln sie sparen hier und
da ein das sind nur anfangs schätzung
sie schaffen darüber hinaus auch
arbeitsplätze bereits jetzt sind viele
arbeitsplätze da im cbd bereich in
amerika gibt es ganz legale
arbeitsplätze da ist vernünftiger
jugendschützer ausbildung was da alles
mit einhergeht und sie schaffen endlich
eine pflanze auf unserem boden die die
jahrhunderte und jahrtausende lang
gewachsen ist cannabis es ein
wunderbares eine wunderbare pflanze und
ein könnten bäume stehen lassen wenn sie
holz brauchen machen sie sagten 'du bist
sie denn lieber dass die alkohol trinken
immer nicht dürfte natürlich im zweifel
nein ich bin mittelstands trinken
wir alles sagen der hat ne flasche was
sagen wir dann angenehm zu dem argument
einstiegsdroge da brauche ich nicht mehr
darüber diskutieren wenn das höchste
deutsche verfassungsgericht bereits 1994
das kommt aus der zeit aus unserer zeit
christiane f christiane f ist am bahnhof
herum gerannt und hat wie viele andere
leute auch vorher gekauft aber eine neue
leute haben auch vor muttermilch genoss
schokolade gegessen zuckerrüben übermaß
und so weiter dieser einstieg strom
theorie ist nicht mehr haltbar und sie
führt dazu dass da freue ich mich die
führt so ein bisschen dazu gesagt dass
ich gar nicht mehr haltbar ist also es
ist mir wenn entschuldigung haben sie
einen wissenschaftler weltweit selbst
die menschen die gegen eine cannabis
legalisierung sind sagen nicht mehr
einstiegsdroge
die haben wir die haben wir wir haben
leute die habe ich auch in meinem
jugendgericht ja die kiffen zu viel aber
ich habe auch ganz viele leute in meinem
jugendgericht die saufen zu viel und
wenn dem so ist dann kiffen hier zu viel
obwohl wir eine prohibition politik
haben und da hätte ich in meinen 30
jahren jugendrichter tun ganz oft mit
den jungs sprechen wollen und zwar offen
und ehrlich wieviel tiefste warum gibst
du ist das richtig für dich und so
weiter das konnte ich nicht und das
können auch eltern heute noch nicht weil
der ja immer diese schwerter hängt ja
das ist strafbar das ist strafbar das
interessiert die jugendlichen überhaupt
nicht ob es strafbar ist im gegenteil es
macht die sache noch viel spannender
ich könnte ja sagen müssen ich
glaube ich werde sie nicht aber ich bin
sehr beeindruckt von ihrem enthusiasmus
für das gras wenn sie selber gar nicht
konsumieren ich ins ausland fahren das
konsumieren wissen sie denn dann
überhaupt die wirkung natürlich war auch
jung und dann zwar bin ich ja bis 34
nicht richter gewählt ja
natürlich habe ich gekauft in meiner
schule haben alle gekauft das sind heute
unternehmer staatsanwälte das sind alles
mögliche hilfen für den erfolg finden
sie das auch aber ich freue mich
provozieren aber dann machen sie ist
auch weiter so okay dass das führt ja
auch zu wissen warum ich mich engagiere
das sage ich ihnen mein vater hat sich
tot gesoffen mit diesen ganzen
geschichten die da drum herum sind die
bräuche nicht ausfüllen ja brauche ich
nicht mein bruder hat zeitgleich gekifft
war in der käfer szene über 15 jahre 16
jahre ja den hat man stigmatisiert
kriminalisiert und schließlich in den
knast gebracht so und dann frage ich
mich ja hätte man meinen vater nicht in
den knast bringen müssen weil er säuft
nein weil es mein bruder in den knast
gebracht weil wir ja ein schützenfest
mental bin übrigens mitglied von 2
schütz und vorhanden ja ich weiß als
droge an um das nochmal klar dass hier
ein wildwuchs mittel aber es ist auch
eine allheilmittel für viele vor 5000
jahren haben dass die alten chinesen
lutz heutzutage 100.000 menschen
cannabis als rezept bevor sie 45 jahre
durften sie es noch nicht mal als rezept
unterbrechung gebet lessing würde ich
gerne helga fragen wenn es jetzt legal
würden sie gemeinsam mit herr müller
wissen wir ja die zeit ist vorbei
die zeit also 16 17 ich denke wir haben
alle gekämpft und
natürlich das problem das problem was
sie gar nicht ansprechen ist und das
habe ich gelesen die risiken also
medizinische risiken habe ich gelesen
sind doch da nicht zu unterschätzen also
eine sache
prostatakrebs wird beeinflusst durch
cannabis konsum warum wer warum
nehmen sie das nicht zu erkennen oder
wollen sie das nicht zur kenntnis nehmen
und
ist das für sie nicht wichtig also ich
denke das kann man nicht mehr weg
deswegen alles wird irgendwie
beeinflusst durch irgendwas wenn sie zu
viel zucker essen wird es möglicherweise
dazu führen dass sie irgendwie zu dick
wird wenn sie dies oder jenes machen
wird das auch jedes mal jedes mittel ja
das wird auch so gesagt nun habe ich
aber in meiner schulklasse waren wollt
alle am kiffen und die sind heute ein
einzelbeispiel
es geht um erziehung und dass wir uns
also bei mir und war das wohl so es gab
diese käfer szene und die trink sehen ja
und das ist eigentlich schlecht wir
müssen und die kinder die gekifft haben
einen jugendlichen jugendliche warnt die
anderen morgen von der schule angefangen
zu kiffen ja und da muss man eigentlich
den leuten sagen zu kiffen es wie wenn
man viel alkohol trinkt ja es ist beides
drogenkonsum dass man beides
betäubungsmittel das ist beides ernst zu
nehmen ja ich kann nicht betrunken in
die schule gehen ich kann nicht in die
schule gehen ja dass man ab und an weit
einmal die woche ein bisschen mehr
trinkt oder noch gift so sollten wir das
glaube ich verankern und beibringen dass
das so benutzt wird und dann sollen die
leute auch nicht zu irgendeinem
niedergehen der ihn dann irgendwann mal
gestrecktes teuer oder anderes zeug
geben sondern das soll man genauso
kaufen wie eine vernünftige zwar schon
einen juristen sind ja wir sind ja auch
wenn wir auf dem boden des grundgesetzes
surfen abgesehen ja ich bin alt
geschworen ich darf noch ein wort dazu
erstmal danke schön ja also wir haben
begriffen dass schule gesessen und die
lehrer haben sie haben sich nicht
getraut uns rauszuschmeißen weil sie
angst davor hatten dass dieser je von
ihnen geliebten schüler möglicherweise
sind strafverfahren bekommen dass das am
sie gerade schön danke natürlich gibt es
probleme bei dem einen oder anderen aber
diese probleme sind im verhältnis zu der
auch zu den problemen die durch die
prohibition
wir gekommen sind weltweit übrigens
millionen von toten durch kriege und und
und der kampf gegen die drogen
ausgerufen von richard nixon ja
1968 der ist lange verloren
sie das ins verhältnis setzen ist es so
ähnlich wie ja natürlich ist es herr
müller waren jetzt noch mal eine frage
waren ob sie frau das geld komplett
überzeugt haben schon dachte ich mir ich
hab mal mit dem csu müller wunderbarer
mann entwicklung sind entweder durch
die top teams gehabt am schlag am
schluss sagte er jetzt bin ich 49
prozent dafür
ja für die legalisierung dann hab ich
gesagt die 51 prozent hinter csu
geschuldet ich kann eine sache sagen ich
bin total gegen die legalisierung auch
jetzt noch aber es hat noch nie ein gast
bei 498 so vehement team aufgenommen
werden auch weitere abbrechen oder
jahres genau erklären werden sie in der
nächsten sendung erkläre er
ändert das höre ich ganz offen das
werden sie auch noch machen die ich
prophezeie es ihnen wenn sie nämlich
erst mal griff